[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique on
parle aujourd'hui emploi avec cette
question au centre du débat est il
vraiment si facile de trouver un travail
en traversant la rue quatre invités sur
ce plateau patrick franchise qui est le
président des hôteliers restaurateurs
pour le département du jura
face à lui damien pagnon celi secrétaire
départemental de la cgt du territoire de
belfort etienne boyer est chargé lui de
l'orientation de l'emploi la formation
au medef de franche comté et puis
martial bourquin c'est le sénateur ps du
doubs alors la scène se déroule dans les
jardins de l'elysée un jeune chômeur se
plaint auprès d'emmanuel macron de ne
pas trouver du travail
on écoute ou ré écoute ce que lui répond
le président de la république je
traverse la rue vous en trouve
ils veulent simplement des gens qui sont
prêts à travailler avec les contraintes
du métier
moi je le som un moment forcément ça me
pose pas de problème c'est les deux
jeunes années c'est bien mais là il me
rappelle jamais
[Musique]
l'histoire se finit bien puisque ce
jeune chômeur a trouvé un travail dans
une entreprise comme cariste premier
tour de table pour voir comment on
réagit nos invités face à ces propos d'
emmanuel macron on va commencer avec
vous le représentant de la cgt vous avez
fait des bonds devant votre téléviseur
je crois qu'on peut dire a fait des
bonds en tout cas oui ça a été très
marquant en fait comme comme remarque en
tout cas stigmatisant ou du moins avec
un peu paraître de certaines mesures
dégradant pour tous ceux qui cherchent à
travailler effectivement c'est une
remarque relativement violente
martial bourquin vous aussi vous avez
senti du mépris pas seulement du mépris
il y a 6 millions deux cent quarante
mille personnes inscrites au chômage en
france selon le bit et i nationale du
travail rude et il ya trois cent mille
demandes d'emploi non satisfaites
c'est dépassé il sait très bien qu'il
n'ya pas un travail pour chacun
simplement il ya un vrai problème c'est
l'adaptation de la demande et l'offre
d'emploi on voir en série à une filière
dont on peut parler mais c'était c'était
absolument déplacé etienne boyer vous
vous avez réagi comment je vous rappelle
que vous êtes chargé de la commission
emploi formation et l'orientation au
medef de franche comté une formule mais
j'attends deux choses qui sont deux
réalités que nous observons tous les
jours dans la région
la première c'est ya du travail il ya du
travail il ya des travail des travaux
quand vous voulez rentrer dans tous les
domaines d'activité et deuxièmement
c'est pas en ce temps chez soi qu'on en
trouve affronter le talent est un peu
plus loin que de simplement de l'autre
côté de la rue mais quand on cherche du
travail
aujourd'hui en franche comté on peut en
trouver alors dans la restauration ça se
passe comment est ce que vous vous en
proposer du boulot exactement alors
traversé la rue c'était une image on a
peut-être mis le président a peut-être
mis un peu la lumière sur cette
problématique par rapport à nos métiers
mais je dirais qu'en traversant la rue
il faut déjà passer sur les passages
cloutés
sinon on risque de se faire écraser et
surtout moi quand je dis passait sur le
passage clouté
c'est pour moi c'est la formation c'est
la transmission des savoirs c'est un
vrai métier et nos métiers
parce que c'était peut-être on a dit
peut-être méprisant à l'égard des
chômeurs c'est un peu méprisant au
ciment par rapport à vos travaux métier
à vous
ça voulait dire tu sais rien faire va
donc dans l'hôtellerie restauration
c'est pas si simple que ça on cherche à
la fois des personnes qualifiées certes
on peut aussi trouver d'autres personnes
pour les former dans nos métiers mais
mais c'est pas si simple
alors je me suis laissé dire que dans le
jura est partout en franche comté il ya
des restaurateurs qui ont refusé du
monde des clients cet été parce que
justement il n'avait pas suffisamment de
monde en salle pour servir vrai ou faux
vrai vrai on a même certains de mes
collègues ou même retirés des tables de
la terrasse ou pas que le client ait
l'impression qu'on leur refuse qu'on
refuse de le servir
puisqu'il manquait en effet du personnel
surtout en salle
je dirais que mais c'est comme ça ses
chroniques ça vous arrive depuis
plusieurs années c'est on le sentait
arriver mais mais cette année on a battu
des records c'est historique pour nous
ce manque de personnel et je dirais sur
la saison certes mais en amont de la
saison alors n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez aussi commenté cette émission et
les propos d' emmanuel macron pourquoi
pas grâce à twitter avec le hashtag dit
mme paul fc comme dimanche en politique
fc alors l'équation est relativement
simple en fait deux chiffres pour
l'illustrer alors le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi ne baisse pas ou peu
en bourgogne franche comté actuellement
il y à 2 115 mille demandeurs d'emploi
pour les catégories à b et c
c'est-à-dire les gens qui travaillent
peu ou pas du tout et les entreprises
donc dans le même temps proposent des
postes qu'il ne trouve personne pour les
occuper par exemple donc vous en franche
comté
vous dites qu'il ya combien de postes
vacants dans l'hôtellerie restauration
pour le stim entre 1000 1200 postes
vacants dans la cas dans la période
automne notamment la saison voilà le
dire comme cheese bon alors les chiffres
les mettent en relation quand même oui
vous voyez tout à l'heure on disait il
ya de l'emploi faut faire attention à ce
qu'on dit parce que il ya de l'emploi
pas pour tout le monde
malheureusement il n'a pas pour tout le
monde alors été renvoyé parce que on
sent et vous disiez combien pour l'
hôtellerie restauration en franche-comté
1200 le non pourvus voilà entre 1000 et
1200 des deux chiffres
on n'est pas du tout dans les mêmes on
est dans un chômage de masse oui en
bourgogne franche comté
par contre ce qui est dommage c'est que
des secteurs en tension n'en trouve pas
alors c'est le même cas dans l'industrie
il y as combien actuellement d'emplois
dans l'industrie en franche comté qui ne
trouve pas preneur culte email plus de
6000 aujourd'hui dans des différentes
branches de l'industrie des dans les
différents métiers
c'est plus de 6000 emplois répertoriés
par pour l'emploi en sachant que une
offre d'emploi simple on ne va pas vers
pôle emploi qui lisent qui fait son
recrutement
malheureusement que pour l'emploi malgré
tous ces efforts lettre c'est le travail
qui est fait ne pourra pas pour voir cet
emploi donc si les chiffres officiels
sont à plus de 6000 cirque l'arrêter
c'est bien au-dessus de 10000 emplois
dans l'industrie non pourvus en franche
comté
alors oui si on additionne le telle
restauration l'industrie on entend
parler aussi du bâtiment de l'aide à
domicile etc
il ya quand même des choses à faire si
vous le voulez bien pour qu'on ait un
vrai débat et je venais là pour ça
qu'elles les emplois est ce que ce sont
des emplois à durée déterminée est ce
que sont des emplois à mi-temps
la précarité a gagné de façon
impressionnante et si on ne prend pas en
compte tous à y compris parfois pour
trois emplois il faut une personne parce
que c'est des mutants dans l'est le
service à la personne
il ya des personnes qui sont prises et
qui ont des fois trois boulots et faut
regarder la qualité des emplois et
ensuite si on veut un vrai débat il faut
parler de l'attractivité de ces filières
parce que depuis des années j'étais
responsable de la formation
en franche-comté vice-président opposé
régional au conseil régional
et on parle des mêmes choses sur les
mêmes filières depuis un certain temps
sur l'industrie je vraiment très attaché
à l'industrie il faudra arrêter de
parler de l'industrie uniquement en
termes négatifs a tonné au vent va être
fait réagir g la cgt puisque l'on a
entendu trois autres invités vous
comment vous voyez ça avec j'allais dire
votre lorgnette à vous de syndicalistes
à la vue qu'on a effectivement partage
certaines choses qui ont été dites ici
par contre moins ce que chez par exemple
des exemples très concrets dans les
entreprises jeu c'est globalement par
exemple sur une usine comme alstom
aujourd'hui à 80 postes qui sont on sait
à pourvoir
parce qu'il n'existe pas pour autant on
met pas en face les embauches
parce que il suffit pas de remplir les
carnets de commande pour pouvoir
embaucher derrière il faut aussi qu'une
révision industriel politique
industrielle une stratégie dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui on parle de la
gpu c'est justement à ce testeur gps et
la gestion prévisionnelle de l'emploi et
des compétences qui aujourd'hui est
davantage un outil pour accompagner du
changement de la transformation plutôt
qu'un vrai outil d'anticipation des
entreprises on le constate un avocat des
entreprises c'est quelque chose qu'ils
avaient en prégnant et ça c'est vraiment
des sujets de fond où je pense que là il
faut aussi qu'on puisse échanger là
dessus parce que ça c'est le coeur au
fond du problème finalement c'est
d'avoir ces métiers qui sont pas pourvus
alors que effectivement il ya des
besoins qu'on peut trouver les
compétences aussi parce qu'à un moment
propos c'est là que la question de la
formation aussi parce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il ya des mutations dans
les emplois tous ces emplois qui vont
muter de demain comment s'est pris en
compte
quelle proposition peut faire aux
salariés moi je pense aussi aux pubs ou
que mettre en lien avec les nouvelles
lois sur la formation où je suis pas
convaincu que si ces salariés qui
responsables de sa formation
par manque de parlant justement de
cohésion dans la politique industrielle
je pense que là y compris le salarié
sont favoris on va faire réagir donc le
patron d'un d'un hôtel restaurant vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que dit la cgt
oui je suis en partie d'accord on voit
bien que dans nos métiers on y vient en
premier par passion viennent passer un
choix par défaut voilà mais on a 3 2 3
catégories il ya les passionnés y aller
pourquoi pas pourquoi j'irais pas dans
cette profession par manque de
connaissance par image on va essayer de
s'en approcher
et puis par défaut parce qu'à un moment
donné les parents ils savent plus où
mettre leur leurs enfants dit bastien va
pas faire du service en salle mais cela
est à cela ils tiennent parle pas on est
bien d'accord mais on est prêt nous nous
venons en tous les cas nono porte à des
futurs employés dans nos maisons qu'on
peu fort mais on on a dans notre adn
nous vraiment la culture de deux là
justement en parlant du soir un chiffre
mais ce que le chiffre on a vraiment
semblé énorme en bourgogne franche comté
le budget de la formation est de 110
millions par an pour la formation des
chômeurs mais vous ce que vous cherchez
c'est pas que des passeurs dette
être si j'ose dire non surtout pas vos
métiers évoluent qu'on parlait de
l'évolution des métiers dans l'industrie
on peut le comprendre
chez vous aussi ça évolue exactement
nous loue les légendes de salles
aujourd'hui ce plus dans l'accueil c'est
plus de parler des produits parler de sa
région d'avoir ce contact humain fort
c'est ça c'est sale c'est d'avoir le
sourire c'est un vrai métier en avoir le
sourire
je le dis souvent on vient plus
facilement dans un restaurant d'un doux
sourire où la société est simple normal
que l' inverse on a une super assiette
ou le serveur vous vous dire la tire
quoi retirer toute l'importance et
etienne boyer vous vous occupez de la
commission formation orientation et
emploi au au medef vous fait aussi
partie du crédoc c'est l'organisme qui
gère justement ces plans de formation
avec la région avec l'état avec les
syndicats le patronat
ces 110 millions vous en faites quoi
c'est une c'est une bonne question mais
je voulais partir et je vous en remercie
mais je vais d'abord revenir sur le type
d'emploi les emplois dont je parle c'est
essentiellement du cdi dans des métiers
qualifiés avec les rémunérations
afférentes
donc on pourra parler rémunération da
par les ans maintenant puisque vous en
écouter dans l'industrie je vais prendre
plusieurs exemples d'abord savoir que
nous n'avons pas de minima qui soit en
dessous du smic dont tous les salariés
sont payés au dessus du smic
un régleur sur machines de production
simple dire le démarrage c'est entre
1700 et 2200 euros bruts par mois selon
l'expérience selon cnt si on parle par
exemple est un outil heures d'un
usineurs on part nettement au-dessus de
2000 euros si on parle des soudeurs
soudeur très spéciale et on peut même
arriver à 2005 premiers lots dont on est
sur des réductions alors c'est bien payé
dans l'industrie que dans l'hôtellerie
restauration
oui à un peu mieux mais mais mais bon
c'est pas trop le la bataille des
chiffres de salaire mais en tous les cas
je peux vous dire que nous l'escalier
les avancées sociales se fait assez
rapidement
un jeune aujourd'hui qu'on en plan début
de autour de 1200 euros à le premier
leucate il arrive ça c'est le smic 1
puisque smic est un pont 185
la rive a sonné aux 39 heures on arrive
à peu près à 1250 mhz et très vite y
gravit les échelons et très vite y est
l'on va faire réagir sur la formation
parlant de l'attractivité
pendant des années on a travaillé sur
l'attractivité de l'industrie en passant
de tels problèmes
oui parce que vous avez une image de
marque les usines c'est sale c'est
brillant eonia mal payés et puis ça
ferme
c'est intéressant ce que vous venez de
dire les unes sa ferme ça fait deux ans
de suite en france où le solde entre les
usines qui ferment et ouvre est positif
ça fait deux ans que en france on
n'ouvre plus du sinn qu'on enferme su
briller jeu et au budget par manque du
crédoc
j'avais le l'étude du credoc g où cette
inadéquation entre la demande et l'offre
très franchement on a perdu presque 3
millions d'emplois dans l'industrie
croyez pas que dans les consciences
ça joue quelque chose à dire quand on
ouvre son journal n'ouvre eux ça va ça
va être la france jouera miss ternois je
vois arriver mais disons le disons le on
parle souvent souvent des de ces
problèmes est inévitablement un papa ou
une maman vers son enfant va dire 20
dans des filières d'avenir fait
attention
oui et c'est là où je partage
certainement ce que vous dit tout à
l'heure
d'attractivité c'est quoi ces salaires
conditions de travail sur la durabilité
du contrat de travail
c'est à dire des cdi et en sachant quand
même que l'industrie à rembaucher
beaucoup beaucoup en intérim moi je
connais des personnes dans ma ville qui
ont fait jusqu'à 3-3 mission d'intérim
de suite avec une promesse d'embauché
ils n'ont pas été embauchés alors vous
répondez quoi etienne boyer ans je
réponds vous lisez répond je ne partage
pas votre votre vous laisser répondre
oui jeu et après on vous dit
à l'origine toutes les firmes maintenant
le même problème donc je pense que le
problème va bien au delà de l'image
d'une filière est une question de
relation avec le salariat une question
de relation et que travail qu'est-ce
qu'on n'a pas entendu un an et demi que
le travail allait disparaître
vous faites référence à benoît hamon
pendant la campagne reculer les entend
aller
un vrai sujet sinon sur est ce que le
travail d'historien je pense qu'il ya un
problème autour de ça sinon on
constatera pas que toutes les filières
on sait pas un problème d'image je veux
revenir sur la formation
la réalité aujourd'hui ici de ses 110
millions beaucoup d'excellentes choses
qui sont faites
comment se fait-il j'ai pas la réponse
j'ai pas de solution malheureusement
c'est comment se fait-il que des
formations rémunérées vers des métiers
où il ya une assurance de d'emploi
derrière métiers de l'usinage du
tournage aurait tous les métiers de
l'industrie ne soit pas rempli comment
se fait-il que des demandeurs d'emploi
cette union comment se fait-il qu'en
franche-comté à besançon wales un clou
quand on cherche douze demandeurs
d'emploi pour former des outils heures
pour l'emploi fait un travail tournaire
contact des milliers de personnes et à
la fin il y en a huit ou neuf
on est très content alors je vais pas du
tout montré dans la question des bus est
ce que les français sont trop feignants
c'est par exemple on va c'est pas très
élevé mais oui mais enfin c'est en tout
cas je vous dis tout ce n'est pas le
sujet ce n'est pas la question
où est la cgt vous pensez quoi tout ça
je pensais que les français sont des
feignants non je pense pas que les
français sont définir déjà deux points
j'aimerais aussi quand même revenir ce
que ça fait lien parfaitement ce qui
était dit aux suites à la phrase
emmanuel moqueront tout à l'heure la
question cruciale de quel travail
qu'elle emploie il faut qu'on en reparle
aussi de ça parce que traverser la rue
aussi ça voudrait dire que n'importe qui
peut faire n'importe quel travail et
c'est sur le sens du travail aujourd'hui
qu'on a besoin de travail c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très prégnant
jaunisse et ça c'est ça aussi qui
causent des souffrances au travail
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui traverse
énormément à la société on peut
l'expliquer aussi à travers ça c'est le
sens du travail c'est absolue dit parce
que d'avoir deux faire croire qu'il n'y
aurait que des travail tout serait
superposables qu'on peut remplacer des
êtres humains parce qu'au final c'est
comme être humain qu'il faut encore le
travail
une façon pour disputer aussi les
transitions iliad il ya des choses à
faire évoluer aussi là dedans mais en
tout cas ce travail un moment il est
réservé et alizée quand même par l'homme
est un moment si c'est pas la question
cruciale elle n'est pas prise en compte
la de remettre l'homme aussi au centre
de la question on aura toujours ces
phénomènes de souffrance et les
évolutions elles se feront toujours en
difficulté parce qu'on n'aura pas mis en
capacité le travail de s'adapter à
l'homme et aux réalités d'aujourd'hui ça
c'est le premier point il y avait là
deuxième malaisie le nom wii ou sinon on
peut repartir quand on parle
d'adaptabilité vous vous entreprises
vous avez de moins en moins de jeunes
qui veulent venir dans l'hôtellerie
restauration qui a mauvaise réputation a
priori il ya certains patrons qui ne
payent pas les heures supplémentaires
qu'ils traitent leurs salariés pas très
bien vous faites comment vous faites
oui comme dort avec les branches et
quand c'est déjà un métier qui est
difficile avec des horaires décalés on
est debout tout le temps et c'est vous
faites comment pour adapter votre
entreprise à vous pour garder vos gens
si j'ose dire
bon j'ai la chance moi ça fait dix ans
que j'ai transformé mon entreprise j'ai
changé d'endroit
ça fait dix ans que j'ai tous mes
salariés qui me suit depuis dix ans
approuvent peut-être que sais-tu plutôt
une bonne chose mais savez-vous la selva
votre recette alors qu'on veut c'est à
dire de ton patron un oui je sais c'est
un peu notre discours nos niveaux de
l'umih c'est c'est qu'il faut changer
nos avec la société changer de mentalité
pourquoi faire venir quelqu'un le matin
à 8h30 alors qu'il est pas obligé d'être
là c'est à dire qu'il faut une vraie
souplesse dans l'entreprise c'est du cas
par cas
c'est des discussions avec avec nos
salariés moi j'ai des exemples concrets
une une jeune fille qui l'appuient chez
nous depuis un moment qu'un enfant elle
veut garder son enfant le soir on
organise le travail pour qu'elle
travaille que du matin quoi qu'elles
fassent le service du matin jusqu'à 16
heures j'ai un autre jeune homme
irresponsable cuisine qui est séparée et
piqué a deux enfants il râle ricken tous
les quinze jours un cuisinier dans un
restaurant qui a ses week-ends
tous les quinze jours les quatre joué
quinze jours mais bon j'avais vraiment
envie de garder bien sûr mais c'est
important ce que je sais ce que je
voulais appuyé sur le fait qu'il n'ya
pas toujours que le salaire qui entrent
en jeu
1 c'est important mais il ya vraiment le
bien-être dans l'entreprise le cadre de
vie qui compte beaucoup et c'est
vraiment je travaille beaucoup là-dessus
alors j'ai l'acheminement du temps et de
l'énergie un voilà d'être une entreprise
peut être importante puisque on est on
est dix neuf dans notre entreprise
on peut faire un peu des rotations
malgré qu'on est ouvert tous les jours
et qui a quand même les repos a donné
les deux jours de repos et ses râles
puces les deux jours de repos par
semaine exactement plus les
les congés mais il faut rappeler non en
franche comté c'est dans notre secteur
c'est 90 % des entreprises ont moins de
cinq salariés
c'est des petites structures il ya
beaucoup de rural il ya moyen de
s'arranger
ça voulait envoya et c'est difficile à
la fois mais voilà ce qu'est ce que vous
quel était votre deuxième point deuxième
point je veux juste revenir aussi
rapidement avec les se fait lien aussi
encore avec ce qui a été dit avant mais
sur les créations d'entreprises il ya
plus de créer des entreprises qui se
créent que dans une usine qui ferme mais
j'allais dire oui parce que là du coup
on aussi le phénomène de sous traitance
par rapport aux grands groupes aussi ils
externalisent énormément leur production
donc on se retrouve effectivement dans
le tissu économique des tpe pme ce qui
est premier pourvoyeur d'emplois
aujourd'hui à ceva qui crée la dynamique
et pour autant il se retrouve aussi
pressurisée par ces mêmes grands groupes
qui aujourd'hui on le voit aussi bientôt
encore très prochainement des annonces
chez general electric qui eux veulent
faire des remontées de cash immédiate
pour financer effectivement des
dividendes et ça c'est un vrai enjeu et
ça c'est plus une politique survient ce
que j'ai et à l'heure c'est une
politique vision industrielle à long
terme
allez court termiste parce qu'on est sur
la rentabilité financière en même temps
on empêche aussi les petites entreprises
par cette construction là éventuellement
d'avoir un business-plan elle aussi pour
se développer parce que ça aussi ça
aussi ça peut aussi les réduire pas que
c'est pas le seul facteur mais ce sens
fait quand même partie on parlait on
parlait des salaires on a réussi où on a
reçu une question d'un téléspectateur
qui s'appelle emmanuel et qui dit que ou
n'a pas intérêt à aller travailler pour
gagner 11 100 euros par mois c'est vrai
nous smic avec les frais de transport et
les impôts
est-ce que c'est pas plus facile de
rester à la maison mais vous dites quoi
ça aussi c'est un petit peu raccourci
aussi par contre je pense que je partage
aussi ce qui a été dit on se le dit
comme ça le mieux vivre dans
l'entreprise et au travail ça peut être
une réalité
effectivement se déplacer peut-être pour
1100 euros à 20 km des fois ça peut
péjore effectivement on peut avoir à
l'achat d'un véhicule qu'on n'avait pas
avant des choses comme ça quelque part
j'ai à dire chiche et si on a les
transports les services publics à
disposition si on a toutes ces questions
là qu'on peut regarder effectivement si
les horaires de travail parce que
légèrement différée mais s'inscrit dans
une démarche de bonnes martial bourquin
vous vouliez à y revenir sur cette
question d
et travaux qualifiés des métiers
qualifiés ont du mal à trouver il faut
savoir qu'on a la suisse à côté nous qui
nous fait une concurrence forte
je rappelle dans des entreprises du pays
de montbéliard certains postes qualifiés
disparaissait dans la nuit à dire qu'ils
étaient tous avaient un salaire très
important en hôtellerie restaurants et
pas que dans l'industrie oui alors
sachez bien faut vraiment faire en sorte
que la france redevienne puissance
industrielle ça c'est franchement si on
passe à gommer tout à l'heure vous
disiez que les entreprises fermaient
justement juste c'est un peu contre a
dit mais elles ont fermé
je ne peux pas descendre très bas c'est
ça voulait dire bien sûr et là quand on
perd 3 millions d'emplois dans
l'industrie en 20 ans 25 ans vous pensez
bien que la question qui se pose
maintenant c'est de retrouver une
vitalité industriels et c'est pour cela
que la question de la main d'heure avec
la question de l'investissement on en
parlait tout à l'heure sont des
questions essentielles
c'est pour cela que moi au sénat je me
bats pour qu'il y ait le sur
amortissements que les pme tpe qui
veulent investir puisse le faire et 40 %
de l'investissement est pris en charge
par l'état sur la fiscalité directe et
donc avec des investissements comme
celle-là en redonnant une image
vous savez ce qu'on disait auparavant on
dit que l'industrie s'était foutu et
c'était les services qu'elle est la
remplacer on a appelé ça l'idéologie
post industrielle
il faut définitivement finir avec cette
idéologie là et parler d'une industrie
forte avec des services fort parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne vend plus un
produit on voit aussi un produit des
services qui vont avec et c'est avec une
parliez de sens tout à l'heure en
donnant du sens aux choses en disant
voilà on va se faire une vraie politique
industrielle
pendant vingt ans la france a perdu pied
ces questions là et avec là on donne
l'envi à des jeunes ingénieurs des
jeunes diplômés mais aussi des ouvriers
de se dire je vais faire ma carrière
dans l'industrie
j'aurai un travail à durée indéterminée
et je pourrais faire ma carrière
fait ravi j'ai juste comme vous êtes un
spécialiste de la formation est ce que
vous avez des formations qu'ils soient
vraiment adaptées aux besoins des
entreprises parce que par exemple les
métiers de la sécurité
il ya relativement peu de formations en
franche comté alors ça ça va me
permettre de parler de l'orientation
j'adore bouge à dire que j'étais
complètement d'accord avec ce que vous
dites bien évidemment les je trouve que
c'est extrêmement rassurant de voir par
là que le patronat d'un côté un
socialiste de l'aude je précise juste
comme ça pour une émission de
l'industrie sont trans court
complètement et y est on va laisser
etienne boyer continuer allez-y sur la
question de l'orientation les tons que
vous prenez est important parce que tu
es ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui un jeune
n'en parle plus des chômeurs rompu les
demandeurs d'emploi mais un jeune bien
je veux bien orienté a de fortes chances
de ne pas devenir demandeur d'emploi
pourquoi il ne s'oriente pas on pas
assez vers des métiers où il ya du
travail
c'est une bonne question un petit l'écho
des femmes rien il les connaît là bien
méritée sûreté sécurité
il ya un bac professionnel il ya deux
sections en bourgogne franche comté dans
le dans l'enseignement public de bac pro
ça fait deux classes de trente deux
classes de plus tôt 25.30 et andrew hill
on prenne un sur dix donc la nièce
aveugle s voilà certes ils ont tous du
travail c'est à dire qu'il ya dix fois
plus de jeunes qui veulent rentrer dans
cette formation assure que l'éducation
nationale ne l'ouvrent je ne suis pas le
plus à même pour elle de répondre à
cette question mais en face et voilà
orientation les sections il ya un temps
déjà et dire un temps de réaction d'une
grosse machine comme l'éducation
nationale peut-être pour se mettre en
place et on travaille de plus en plus
dans l'orientation la mise en commun de
moyens de formation
les progrès sont virés constant entre
entre l'industrie entre l'économie de
l'éducation nationale je pense que
malheureusement on regard des besoins
on ne va pas si vite kan veut dire sur
l'industrie ce que vous aviez bien sûr
complètement vrai et ça donne du sens à
tout l'effort dans ce que vous dites
mais aujourd'hui la semaine dernière il
va me preneur à besançon - le premier
salon européen des microtechniques donc
presque tous les stands y avait des
affiches non pas sur les produits des 30
points assure t on recherche bombe
xala compétences donc aujourd'hui ce qui
freine le développement des entreprises
sur amortissements c'est évident qu'il
faut le faire vous avez raison mais le
frein au développement des entreprises
aussi aujourd'hui c'est l'absence de
compétences alors qu'est ce que vous
imaginez qu'on a on a des jeunes de 15
ans des filles et des garçons les deux
qu'est ce que vous leur dites pour aller
dans l'industrie vous allez 30 secondes
pour défendre
venez venez nous voir il ya un
dispositif qui marche très bien avec le
nom de l'emploi c'est les mises en
situation
le prenne de la formation si on propose
un demandeur d'emploi venez vous former
dans sa tête ses écoles et souvent on
est sortis du système scolaire en échec
donc la bonne
vraiment ce qui marche bien on le fait
de plus en plus avec pôle emploi c'est
de la mise en situation venait à me
dépasser une journée deux journées
découvrir le monde de l'entreprise
découvrir des molécules et des lieux les
médias ont les verts venaient voir les
meuniers et ça ça marche et je voulais
demander pas la même chose la même chose
pour l'hôtellerie-restauration qu'est ce
que vous leur dites aux jeunes alors je
totalement d'accord avec ce que vous
dites il faut venir en immersion dans
l'entreprise pour nous c'est important
alors on a aussi aussi j'veux pas drac
automne et que client dans un restaurant
dans les cuisines mer en salle et est ce
que je pense aussi c'est qu'on est
vraiment dans un problème sociétal
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que les jeunes
à 15 16 ans et ce qu'ils ont et ce
qu'ils savent ce qu'ils vont faire dans
leur avenir
est-ce qu'on peut aujourd'hui dire tu
vas faire trimer ville dans l'industrie
vous allez parler de métier patients en
quoi vous avez 10 secondes
en quoi c'est passionnant votre métier
vous en cuisine c'est passionnant parce
que ce qu'on aime nous dans nos métiers
7,7 partir d'un produit brut un produit
fini ça demande un vrai travail de la
fourche à la fourchette je le dis
souvent mais c'est également
on le voit il ya un tiers des jeunes qui
sont intéressés par nos métiers qui sont
qui sont émerveillés parce que tout ce
qu'on voit à la télévision ce top chef
c'est fini c'est donner du plaisir aux
gens
voilà merci messieurs d'avoir participé
à cette émission c'est voilà vous
remercier d'avoir voulu ça va vite
martial bourquin
merci d'avoir participé à cette émission
bon dimanche après midi à tous au revoir
[Musique]
on